[Music]
let's go to laney in sacramento what's
up laney
hey dr john how you doing partying dude
what are you up to
um i'm at home with two sick kids
so we're we're partying over here too
man
dude does your house smell like saltine
crackers and the price is right and
sprite
dude all my windows are open and it
smells like straight vomit and sweat in
here oh gross
that's so that sounds like james's car
but go ahead hey so what's up
um well i wanted to call and i'm not
going to give you a ton of back
information up front because i know
you'll kind of dig and get what you need
out but basically my question is just
how do i become the solution to the
problem of
not liking my kids like i love them to
death but i'm finding myself in a place
where i'm
not liking them
not like sometimes but like majority of
the time
that's a great question hey thank you
for
thank you for having the courage to say
that out loud most parents won't say
that because then the shame cycle just
starts right and there were people
looking at them weird so it totally
feels like a taboo subject like even
bringing it up i'm just like am i the
only one that is feeling this because
this is
tough and it sucks
yeah dude how old are your kids
my daughter is six and a half and my son
is four and a half oh gosh
yeah you're right in it man
you are gonna think of it you're right
in it so
um
when did you start not liking them
probably
i started noticing it probably about
a year or two ago
and just kind of dismissed it with oh
well you know i didn't have
that immediate connection with them
after they were born i had postpartum
depression really bad after both of them
and so i just kind of brushed it off
with you know just having those feelings
and that they'll come and go and i'm
just probably irritated because i'm
juggling so many different things but
then i started noticing that i'm like
i talk to them like crap sometimes like
i'll do the same thing my mom did and
just yell at them and then after i yell
at them i'll just like look in the
mirror and just be so disgusted with
myself like how can you say that to your
kid
most of the most of the time i find that
when i am struggling with liking my kids
i always love them
when i talk to people who are struggling
with liking their kids
they don't like their body's response to
their children
yeah
if you've gone through postpartum and it
was heavy
i'm speculating here i don't have any
research studies but this is just me
having
countless conversations
with women who've experienced this um
your body has now put a pin in the story
that that kid equals hurt
that kid equals pain that kid equals
fill in the blank
and every time that kid comes into your
presence it starts up a cycle
that your body's trying to protect you
from
and there's nothing worse than your body
reacting to holding your freaking baby
right
right and then you think something's
wrong with you
and then the loop like there's just no
connection no emotion
and that's your body trying to protect
you
from a story that was real at one point
at one point postpartum depression was
scary as all get out wouldn't it
yeah yeah it was terrifying
and your body's like ah i remember that
story and they were involved
yeah and every scream every everything
rages you up and then you put that on
top of the story you're still carrying
around with you about what you're worth
because of your mom what'd she do to you
um my mom
my mom experienced a lot of hurt in her
life
stop don't go apologizing for her yet
she's a grown-up
what'd your mom do to you
she was a single mom of three kids who
stop apologizing for your mom
what'd your mom do she
she worked all the time so she was never
there sorry she was never there
and when she was it was constant
fighting and i was never good enough
never did anything right
um so i just always felt very worthless
and i know she didn't mean it that way
but
that's what it made me feel as a kid
and um
she just yelled all the time and it
finally got to a point where i started
sneaking out the house and going and
hanging out with friends that i knew i
shouldn't be hanging out with
because i just simply didn't want to be
around her i didn't want to be in her
presence
and i'm starting to
sorry
i'm starting to notice my six-year-old
feel the same way towards me
and it sucks to see this cycle repeat
yeah
and so the great terry reel
the great therapist terry reel says
family trauma is like a forest fire that
rages through
family history until somebody has the
courage to turn and face it and say no
more
and you my sister lainey you're going to
get burned in the process it's going to
hurt
and
those kids of yours and their kids and
their kids after them
will live differently because you chose
and said no more
and yes six and a half year olds can be
wildly annoying they make up crap they
get into stuff they're testing every
boundary and every thought and every
right they're
they're just little button button
pushers because they're trying to figure
out how the world works
and
gosh it could be so annoying so annoying
right yeah like they just bring out the
worst sides of me and like hold on hold
on hold on hold on
i want to stop that okay
you choose to let part of you emerge
when they push certain buttons you're in
control they're
not and i don't feel like i'm in control
i feel like
i just reacted like i know the right
answer in my head but when the situation
arises it's just like
all of my anger and rage is just invoked
and then it's just like i'm constantly
disappointed in my
reactions and
um just feeling like i'm continuing this
unintentionally
repeating the cycle even though that's
the one thing i don't want to do that's
right because you're trying to
instead of slowing down and putting on a
seat belt you're trying to stop the car
crash after the skid's already happening
okay
this stuff gets changed way way way
upstream
and it starts with you
letting seven-year-old laney know
that your mom messed up
she missed out on a pretty awesome
little girl
she missed out on a girl who was funny
and silly
and had lots of energy
and was smart
she missed all of it
through her exhaustion and her rage and
her anger and her dismissiveness
and at some point you gotta go back and
let little laney go because right now
laney is defending you and laney's
running the show little ladies running
the show that's why you act like a
seven-year-old when you respond to your
kids you scream you yell you throw
things and you feel bad about it and
then you repeat
yeah okay
that's a that's a you've probably heard
this and it sounds all woo-woo that's
your inner child saying oh i remember
this i'll come to defense because i've
been defending laney her whole life
because i had to because mom wasn't
there to do it
and you have to look in the mirror and
say adult lane is worth loving
these two kids
did good by me
they're lucky to have me as a mom and
i'm gonna backfill that identity with
new actions and i'm gonna backfill that
identity with new thoughts and i'm gonna
learn new ways this is a tools issue not
a character issue okay
okay you don't have the tools in your
bag to not yell
you don't have another you don't have
another thing to do that's just how you
solve problems
yeah
like we have we have my dad come over on
tuesday nights for taco tuesday and
he'll get to see you know obviously
they're acting out in their attitudes
and my dad was never there for me so i
just kind of take everything he says
with a grain of salt
not being disrespectful or anything but
it's like you can't really give
brotherly advice when you weren't a
father um
and his answer to everything is oh put
them in their room
whoop their butt and i'm like i work at
a mental health counseling agency and
have for the last eight years and i've
learned a lot about positive parenting
and the emotional damage that occurs
with that kind of reactions to their
behavior and his thing is well they'll
learn real quick won't they i'm like
yeah but they'll learn to fear me not
respect me okay
every time you invite your dad over your
body recognizes that bear
and it starts into fight or flight and
you are unable to have good
relationships or interactions with him
because your body's not present with you
it's in defense because that guy was
supposed to have shown up
and that guy was supposed to have loved
you as a daughter and have held you
accountable and hugged you
so tight you couldn't breathe
and he should have stepped between you
and your mom when she was yelling and
screaming he shouldn't have left you
you hear what i'm saying
yeah
and so at some point soon taco tuesdays
need to come to an end
because you think you're doing right by
everything and you're just perpetuating
a fantasy that is keeping your body
fully limbic that is putting those girls
in an unsafe situation and giving access
to this guy who doesn't deserve access
to your family right now because you're
not whole and well yet
i've heard you say before
that it's important to give 30 second
hugs and so um like a week or two ago i
gave i gave both my kids hugs when i
dropped them off at school and
my daughter just she didn't even lift
her arms up she didn't hug me back and
there was no reason for it we didn't
fight that morning or anything but like
when i let go over i just looked at her
and i was like oh so mommy doesn't get a
hug like no i love you don't have a good
day no nothing and she just looked at me
shook her head with this just
look of anger and disgust and like
almost pure hatred towards me
and
it reminded me of the exact same way i
felt as a 16 year old like her face
looked like me at 16. hey laney lady
lainey i want her to feel this laney
she's six
she's six
you know what's going on in the mind of
a six-year-old
nobody knows
one of the things i work really hard and
it's real hard because i have a
six-year-old little girl too
who sometimes will hug me so tight i
can't breathe and it fills my
soul
and then other times i say come give me
a hug i gotta go to work and she's like
no thank you
and my first thought is
because you suck at being a dad because
you're always gone because you're always
lecturing all your kids about screens
and blah blah running your mouth and
they don't think your fart jokes are
funny
and then i have to stop myself and go no
she's six
i am a good dad
and i'm not gonna judge every
interaction as though it's the end of
all time that this is it or that's it
and otherwise i'm not gonna do that i'm
not going to give my daughter
the burden of having to carry my
emotional weight
i'm going to say you don't have to hug
me but i'm going to hug you because i
love you
and then i'm going to leave
i'm gonna teach her you don't get to set
my mom or dad's like emotional state
you're not that powerful you're six
you're little bitty
i'm a grown-up i set my emotional state
and my feelings i make choices about my
behavior you don't have that power
and only then will a kid be able to drop
their shoulders and feel safe and hug
recklessly
and it seems counterintuitive
but your daughter is carrying the weight
of the house the way you had to carry
the weight of the house and it's time to
take that weight off of her shoulders
and take it back
and by the way
laney you're strong
you've been carrying heavy stuff for a
long time
it's just finally breaking it is it is
and then like just to add
just to add more to the situation um my
daughter was about three and a half or
four years old when we had her in a
in-home daycare that was through a
family friend
and a situation happened when she was
four and one of the older kids that was
there he was like seven or eight
they were in the living room while the
daycare person was making lunch and they
were playing house and he told
all the kids that were there there was
like four or five of them that in order
to be married and play house that you
know the girl has the poor pants down
and he has to put his wiener on her butt
so that happened when she was four
and ever since then she has been
way way way overly curious
she'll try to walk in on her brother in
the bathroom she'll try to walk in on
her dad in the bathroom
and now it's it's spilled over into
school stuff and she
um
she's asking kids at school if she can
see their junk and it has gotten to a
point where the principal and i have had
to sit down and basically say like
either she gets into counseling or she
can't come back here
because now when this initial incident
happened did you take her in
immediately
no i did it okay that today
two things there's not an inappropriate
curiosity for kids when it comes to
their body parts and
like that should be an open conversation
and
your child was sexually assaulted
okay and that's scary to say it like
that you've got to treat it as such
and i know that when things happen in
our own homes
that it it's it can be so disorienting
that it's hard to put labels like that
on things that happen in our home
and especially it was just another young
kid and what great
your daughter was sexually assaulted and
she's got to get treatment as such she's
got to learn appropriate body touch
she's got to learn appropriate body
boundaries she's got to become safe in
her own skin
and she has to balance curiosity with
behavior
and she's going to need a professional
to walk her through that
i've got around like six different
waiting lists to see a counselor that's
great that's great
call back and say my daughter was
sexually abused and they'll probably
move you up okay okay and okay you mom
have to stop carrying around that that's
your fault
okay
okay stop
it's not helping her get better it's not
undoing what happened and it's not true
stop
okay
okay i know i know it's just loops and
loops and loops and loops
i'm like i like i told you i had
postpartum and um i had like emotionally
detached from having any more kids
because these two are already
i say such a handful but i mean any kids
with their age or a handful yeah um and
i had like just mentally
my husband had an appointment to get a
vasectomy and i've just been so stressed
out we lost our house a few months ago
so we've just kind of been couch
chopping and
all over the place and i've been so
stressed out that i didn't even realize
i was pregnant again so
oh ao so you got number three coming
yeah
i didn't even find out until i was
almost 16 weeks because i've been so
stressed out about trying to help her
hey i'm smiling
i'm sorry you are okay i'm smiling with
you because this baby is not coming into
the world in
um under a cloud of wish you weren't
here
and that's what i don't want to happen
nope okay then we're going to make that
choice
right
yeah
here's what's got to happen in short
order you have a ton
of chaos a ton of trauma
if we sat down and talked about your
marriage you tell me you could
you got a lot going on you just lost
your house on top of it you've got a
child who sexually assaulted that we
still got to deal with that you're
carrying around the burden of your
mother you're carrying around a lot
you're carrying a lot
the epicenter of this starts with you
deciding you're worth being well
and you don't believe that
nothing on this trajectory changes until
you believe that because then when you
believe you're worth being well that
your marriage is worth being incredible
then you're worth changing your
financial situation and then you're
worth doing the work to heal from your
childhood stuff and then you're worth
filling the blank fill in the blank fill
in the blank
but it's timed today as i just told the
last caller tomorrow starts right now
if you want things to be different
tomorrow it starts right now
you
call those people back where your
daughter's on the waitlist tell her it
was sexual abuse involved
and also
you call somebody and get in today call
somebody and get in today hey listen
hang on the line i'm gonna send you a
copy of my book on your past change your
future and
um we're gonna hook you up with better
help counseling okay better help therapy
i want you to call them there's no
excuses you can see within 24 48 hours
and i'm going to pay for the first month
okay we're going to take care of it for
you but i want you to get on this asap
you're worth being well you got a lot
lot going on and by the way before i
hang up you decide today this is going
to be a little wind no more yelling at
my kids period you're going to make that
choice and when you find yourself
starting to yell you're going to close
your mouth you're going to walk out in
the backyard no more yelling i'm not
giving that to my mom anymore i'm not
giving that to my dad anymore i'm done
we're going to start with that and we're
going to have some small wins around no
more yelling or some small runs around
going to counseling some small ones
around taking care of my daughter and
we're going to keep working on it and
we're going to keep working on it we're
going to keep working on it and we're
going to get well